l'armée française au secours de la corse
les militaires russes qui viennent en
aide à l'italie
huit brigades de virologues de médecins
de l'équipement médical et des complexes
de désinfection sont attendus
aujourd'hui en lombardie une aide
d'urgence décidée par le ministre russe
de la défense sergueï choïgou à la
demande du kremlin
le point sur la situation en russie avec
la correspondance à mouscou d'automne
claireaux et bien le nombre de cas
d'infection au camp la virus en russie
continue d'augmenter il est passé en 24
heures de 306 à 367 61 nouveaux cas donc
dont 54 rien que pour la ville de moscou
et pour chaque personne infectée l'état
de santé de l'entourage mais aussi des
personnes avec qui elle a pris l'avion
le cas échéant sont vérifiées et
justement de nouvelles restrictions ont
été imposées concernant le transport
aérien désormais aucun vol de passagers
ne sera effectuée depuis et vers la
russie
à l'exception de certains vols réguliers
entre moscou et différentes autres
capitales mondiales ainsi que les vols
charters qui rapatrie les citoyens
russes bloqués à l'étranger tous ses
vols internationaux partiront et
arriveront depuis un terminal unique
dédié de l'aéroport de cheremetievo l'un
des trois aéroports de la capitale où
les contrôles seront par ailleurs
renforcé la situation paraît donc
toujours sous contrôle sur le territoire
russe et les autorités en profite donc
pour aider leurs voisins et partenaires
les plus proches
cent mille kits de détection du commis
19 ont été acheminés vers une douzaine
de pays dont la biélorussie l'arménie
l'azerbaïdjan le kirghizstan ou encore
l'ouzbékistan et vous l'avez dit à la
suite d'une conversation téléphonique
entre vladimir poutine et le premier
ministre italien giuseppe compter le
président russe a confirmé
l'acheminement d'une aide médicale
d'urgence à l'italie ainsi trois avions
à bord desquels se trouve du matériel
médical mais aussi des médecins
spécialistes et du personnel soignant
ont décollé aujourd'hui de moscou vers
la péninsule italienne